To make sure we understand this idea, that velocity is proportional to time,
let's look at one example. Let's imagine that we drop a ball.
The instant we drop the ball t = 0, the ball's speed is 0 m/s.
If I wanted to represent this with a picture, I would just draw a stationary ball.
If my acceleration is 10 m/s per second, which we can also say 10 m/s²,
then after 1 second I will have gained 10 m/s.
I can represent this velocity with a downwards arrow.
The length of this arrow somehow represents the size or magnitude of this velocity.
After another second the speed increases to 20, and my arrow is twice as long.
I want you to tell me two things about what happens after 3 seconds.
First, the speed and, second, where should I put the end of this arrow,
which represents that speed. Should I put it here, here, here, or here?